le dispositif fait son premier
anniversaire à Poissy couronné d'un
trophée de l'impertinence ce n'est pas
une start-up qui l'a reçue mais la
Caisse Primaire d'Assurance Maladie pour
ses ateliers sentait active des ateliers
réservés aux assurés uniquement en bonne
santé pour prévenir au lieu de guérir
autour de trois thématiques le dos le
cœur et la nutrition aux commandes
Patrick negaret ce directeur atypique a
lancé le premier atelier en France il y
a 15 ans et depuis la exporter dans 8
départements les dépenses consacrées à
la prévention sont très faibles par
rapport aux dépenses consacrées aux
soins c'est en ça que ça contre courant
parce qu'on a très souvent prédécision
énergiques de réduction de dépenses
d'augmentation des recettes mon a jamais
pris des actions sur un plus long terme
les affections chroniques croisent
constamment c'est les 8 dixièmes de
l'évolution c'est les deux tiers des
dépenses c'est un point considérable et
rembourser des soins c'est une bonne
chose mais finalement l'objectif d'une
caisse c'est plutôt de vous assurer sur
la bonne santé c'est ça l'idée d'origine
de la sécurité sociale
favorise l'accès aux soins c'est pour
que les gens soient bonne santé l'enjeu
est de taille dans les Yvelines les
dépenses de santé s'élèvent à 2,7
milliards d'euros d'autres sites santé
actives vont voir le jour le 19 juin à
Versailles en plein centre-ville et à la
fin de l'année à Guyancourt boulevard
Vauban c'est gratuit ouvert en semaine
jusqu'à 19h et même le samedi prochain
état un service sur Internet tout le
monde peut pas se déplacer tout le monde
le souhaite pas se déplacer non plus et
à l'époque on est sur internet on peut
gagner à la fois l'efficacité en coût et
les gens chez eux disposeront finalement
d'un coaching en ligne via le compte
ameli à compter de l'automne le site de
Poissy compte 1000 personnes inscrites
en France 20 000 assurés ont déjà suivi
le mouvement la moyenne d'âge est de 45
ans et ce sont en majorité des femmes
on a des écoles